one thing that I really want people to
know about darkest hour is that it's got
a lot of humor in it and Churchill
himself had a lot of humor was that
something you particularly wanted to
bring out with him I think it's
something that we all wanted to bring
out I think that from the very
conception of it with Antony McCartan
the writer I went to in my my homework
on the role my experience watching some
of this sort of newsreel footage of him
he did indeed look like a baby he had
this big brown shoe Rubik face and a
sparkle in his eye and it sort of
naughty grin on his foot on his lips and
and had vitality and energy and and and
we know from the writing about witty
that he could be when I read the script
I laughed a lot too and was was charmed
by him but that makeup process was it
almost like a ritual like there became
de guerre iing and it did become a
ritual in a way it would start off very
sort of quiet and Zen and then maybe
would play some music and then about 2
hours and 45 minutes in you start
looking in the mean you know you look in
the mirror and you start to see you know
the spirit essence of Churchill and then
about the three hour point I would start
to rumble and grumble underneath my
breath and you know and it was all it
was mine why I guess it was my way of
finding him
you